milyen stratégiákkal lehet játszani és
olyan kísérteésen hasonlítottak ezek a
stratégiák valamire egy könyvre amit még
évekkel ezelőtt olvastam ez a suncenek a
háború művészete ez egy 2500 éve íródott
könyv amit egy hadvezér írt sununce és
utána pedig még a a a egy egy későbbi
generációban levő
hadvezér kiegészített tehát arról szól
hogy egy háborúban milyen alapvető
stratégiákat ez az is a címe a háború
művészete hogye művészetnek tartja magát
a hadviselést és és annyira népszerű lh
hogy a menedzsment és buiznis körökbe
egy kötelező műnek tehát hogyha most
valaki a hallgató közül beírja a
google-be hogy a top 10 vagy lehet a top
50 biznis könyv a világon tuti ott van
benne a háború művészete ott van a mi
cégünknek a polcán is én is olvastam és
és ez egy alapmű amit meg kell
ismerjenek mert ez valójában ha egy
kompetitív helyzetben vagy az egy olyan
mint egy háború egy olyan mint egy
hadviselés ez függetlenül attól hogy
most egy céget próbálsz egy piacra
bevezetni a termékével vagy vagy egy
menedzsment környezetben próbálsz egy
csapatot összeállítani vagy akár család
családapaként próbálod a a világot
megérteni alapelvekről van szó